one of the things that's been
interesting last couple of months is
that there has been a in my opinion I
think a lot of our opinion a very
refreshing defense of science people all
across the country standing up for
science there was a March for science
and people many people I know took part
in it there were really creative signs
this was one of my favorite social from
the March for science yeah I had nothing
to do with that sign I was like that's
the bartender from the Love Boat yeah
it's weird though
I would say even disturbing that we feel
it's even necessary to march for science
because science shouldn't have to be
marched for it should not need a defense
that's right that's right it's like
saying let me March for the laws of
gravity because someone might try to
repeal them yeah no this is not what you
do with a science and science and part
of it is just the educational system we
have full-grown adults who call
themselves educated who would swear that
they could just cherry-pick science if
it fits their political cultural
religious philosophies and that's not
how science works so I think there's a
missing thing in the K through 12 that
he's needs to be added so that people
can come out and when they say they're
educated it means they know how to
analyze process information and
understand what science is and how and
why it works in the service of
civilization now the US
like Charlie wasn't listening
you